and everybody has been very particularly
mean we were all been waiting for this
grand finale and we thought that what
better way for the grand finale to to
what with better way to start the grand
finale but have praveen actually
introduced John so who by definition is
the jaws longest time collaborator and
of course you know colleague etc so with
that I'll Praveen and healing
thank you very much and thanks to
Mustafa and etc for inviting me thank
you for the honor of introducing young I
heard I mean at least two or three
people said what they read John's papers
there'd be one sentence and the next
sentence but then there to spend a lot
of time going from the previous sentence
to the next sentence even though clear
how you get there ii sympathize with me
when i had two years meeting john every
week and he would write the few
sentences on the board and then i had
the rest of the week to figure out
such as mint mark is likely to come next
so but that experience also allowed me
to work better with succeeding
generations of students so I don't know
what I think of this but if you look at
being the next one and then there is
Andrea and who else is here Steve
lonegan the muscles
students and to very exciting times
graduated 779 and then we shipped them
off for three years to the cold of
Hilliker so then he came back and he
stopped now in the fog of Berkeley for
the next 30 years or so and I hope that
he continues to stay here I was gonna
sort of recap them some of this work I
think Kumar started out with getting
noticed and I would like to go back to
the first days of his PhD work when he
took some known results in queueing
theory but then provided not just
elegant but very insightful
understanding of those theorems such as
the product form theorem for Jackson
networks such as when our successes such
as Sounion times independent
not overtaking condition which looked
kind of bizarre but but that once he
explained it to me perfectly good sense
and on i think the then we came back
from Cornell and I don't know when Bank
got started here the multiple phases but
it also went too far now in the cold to
be a tradition the second phase Aniki
starting in anymore
yes and then he went short migration is
across the street into the mathematics
department and then returned to the
greener side
campus so there's a period of time when
you worked on abandoned problems and
then John got adjusted in control I
think you can so this phase of control
which was still enlightening and keep
control of resources and I'm sorry John
expanded and so I lost touch and then it
came back again with this one's about
interested italics so he in between
there's a lot of stuff that he did
putting these points where the contact
of that was interesting to me because I
was doing economics various chiefly
transmission but there are many similar
issues there congestions with its
congestion infection or connection
security questions or just conduction of
resources thinking about communication
there's high profits
and then got interested in I think
networking started somewhere along the
line and so we worked on this book
together which the second edition and
you joined so that we could talk about
Wireless and there's so many such
periods of time where we came to contact
not directly but because some third
person so for instance Kumar visited per
year and I don't know what a kostas came
back such situation Francois visited
Nick did not visit
but I don't want to drag on thank you
but simply to say so we're looking
forward to get your personal
[Music]
and it's delightful to see old friends
together it's a special pleasure for me
and I thank you very much
I want to thank Avene for the kind words
and so far they're all the words that I
heard I had to pinch myself a few times
to make sure that they were talking
about me and also that I was still alive
and that was I was not having my
so those events always make me a little
bit uneasy and I've attended some
foreign colleagues and I have a mixed
feeling about this but but nevertheless
this is very enjoyable you saw that
Parveen 2 taught me almost everything I
know and more importantly taught me how
to learn the rest that I did not know
yet many people talked about style and
tasteful research and I certainly I got
that for parties in the truth so I will
try to tell you the lessons of 40 years
of networking theory so it's a personal
perspective so the first question
survive I have one minute and 15 seconds
for every year so that's not easy
also there is nothing I can say that you
don't know already that you don't know
probably better than I so this is
clearly an impossibility talk
I tried to convince the organizers that
I did not have to give a talk okay so I
will try to give you a perspective for
years and I restart with one statement
this is not my statement that was made
to me by somebody we want to say cisco
certified engineer and he explained to
me that it does not need any theory to
manage the network or even total
standard the network works which is true
all the said not the statement was made
by a colleague in 1987 that we have
enough theory for the next 15 years and
if you count the dashes you will be able
to recognize the name but I will not
leave you enough time
but then next a note it seems to by
somebody by somebody well-known he said
what's the port of theory you change the
assumptions you get different
conclusions what good is that right
because also easily guess you can tell
it's not Venkat
the next statement ah it's about one of
the inventors on the Internet
we like TCP of the beautiful theoretical
result understanding why it works but he
said well TCP is slowed down when it is
congested the solution we don't need any
theory to really understand getting
easier to get another statement from a
colleague of so that's working the pole
is solved right so there is the tendency
to believe that ok we have sold the pole
like we have solved the power
distribution that will we don't need to
work on this anymore
problem solved it's a commodity we can
buy Network easily RadioShack so it is
indeed the case that you do not need
theory to understand most of the ideas
of networking right the idea of packet
switching of layers internet working how
to connect networks together to the
internet that you have shorter sparse
writing or it's an obvious idea is not
needs theory for that CSMA is the same
and same thing or this you try if you
fail you try and try again right that's
sure
the idea of virtual circuits VLANs and
PLL the sulfonylurea and then the
network management ideas like a simple
network management protocol remote
monitoring software defined Network and
FV whatever that is right all that is
those ideas are innovative
they are disruptive but they are simple
they are extremely valuable because
they've changed the world right so we
should not minimize ideas because of the
simplicity but the point is what you
don't need silly for this so the
question is what is the usefulness of
networking theory so that's what I will
try to discuss by looking back over
before I do that I would like to tell
you my view well my recollections of
Berkeley in 1975 when I came this was
Berkeley in 1970
right so so when I came to my face off
no longer like this so that maybe when
Pauline came it was
I think this is the first building on
cabbage sauce all I think right no so
this is more like this was the popular
culture at the time that was her care at
the time right this was what was popular
on TV so it's a long time ago 1975 the
politics of the birthday was interesting
what Claire was a hotbed of the defense
of his speech right
and you remember 25 hours just after the
end of the Vietnam War and just after
when Nixon design right so that tells
you how much time it spans because I
think to defense be free speech fighting
Portland's walls and questioning the
integrity of the president those are
things that will never happen again
all right the technology was exciting
and that is what pushed me into
engineering in particular into
electrical engineering so when I
finished high school a man walked on the
moon
IBM came out with a 370 computer it was
one of the big computers in the diet and
Intel him at was a 4-bit microprocessor
so that was all around the early
seventies so it was a time where he
believed in the evolution of technology
this was clearly the thing to work on
well more directly relevant for me was
Berkeley what was happening in Berkeley
intellectually well in the early 60s
there was this ephemeral famous book
linear system theory of state space
approach by the scientist or where they
look at the systematic theory for
systems that are linear continuous in
spin State and they try to find a nice
frame electronics and those systems a
little bit later there was a thesis by
Pierre Rameau martingale approach to
processes and it was followed by the
work of a beam so warmed the saw log
hevene via renewable France coupon and
Marc Davis there was a collection of
work that together proposed the
scientific approach to the analysis and
design of systems not only in linear
systems of nonlinear systems of sodium
systems so jump systems are like
confused right so so there was the hope
that you could analyze systematically
systems that befall the prey complicated
by taking a systematic scientific
approach so it is in that spirit that I
started my PhD and I thought when I
looked at Paulus I I try to see what is
the correct way to think about those
forms so why fear in networking I will
make two points while there are major
new challenges that
all the time so at any given time you
say go we have solved the problems but
then very quickly new problems here
right so maybe the problems are with
block chance or and the fallen so maybe
in specialized network like data centers
or some other specialized applications
and also theory I think it's necessary
to see how to deal with those problems
to explain this I would like to give you
my view of innovation process when you
look at the problem the first thing that
you do is that you build a caricature of
the problem so I can't get your meaning
simplified view the taxol creates the
key features of the so this is a word
that Frank Kelly used for scientific
solve for models of systems and I like
that name so you start with the
caricature you use the catcher to get
some out of standing of the system and
then you come up with a scheme that
seems to make sense for that can capture
and then you have to elaborate the
scheme to come up with a design let's
look at an example
you're trying to put something to help
your camera along the road and you trace
thing about it instead gee this doesn't
work too well the the commoners are
preventing the motion so you worked on a
scheme
I really made the car eliminate the
colors you come up with a round wheel
right and then so this is your skin and
then you elaborate that and you have a
design that's simply the point is that
your caricature Elvis is a basic problem
so what you have in mind is not just
this little object is the the real
system the end system so when you choose
your simplified model you must have in
mind the ultimate goal right so you
don't design a caricature just to solve
the toy problem at least in engineering
you have in mind a big system but you
start with a simple view this is another
example you understand that when you see
a paper plane fly the paper plane does
not have to flap its wings so maybe we
can make something fly without flapping
the wings you come up with fixed design
as a simple scheme and then you'll above
it
this is another example that I like you
eat a piece of chocolate I'm from
Belgium we like chocolate cake and then
you chew on a is a lot and you realize
see those two things go well together
the scheme to try to integrate the two
flavors so he tried to explain math you
say okay even chopped hazelnuts and
chocolate we come together then you come
up with this idea okay that's the basic
idea but then you want to elaborate the
design and you come up with
yes Janeiro and be shelf area 1984
another example you look at the
switching board for the phone system and
then you look at the mail sorting room
and you say wow these are two very
different ways of writing information
why can't we wrought electrical signals
the way we write men and then you come
up with a scheme which is a packet
switching then you elaborate it and you
come up with up on it right so the point
is that what you have in mind is
transferring information and then you
say what is the basic scheme you reduce
it to the simplest problem are to write
a piece of information electrical
information
this is another example the familiar you
have two floors that want to share one
link with head see to the source is
transmitting at rate X&Y and they don't
know about each other you say how can
they somehow I agree to use only see up
to each how do you do that well simple
approach will be the this switch will
count the Navajo flows that they are and
say okay there are two flows each one
should get silver to this was the ATM
approach or the in serve approach right
the resources of a shuffle but then no
there is another scheme that says well
if they both increase at the same rate
and then they multiply the rate constant
less than 1 when the the sum exceeds C
then this will converge to 0 to 0 of 2
it will work if you have 5 connections
it will come to 0 function so this is
the aimd
system so that's the scheme that you
find that you understand on a simple
model you would not understand it in a
network because in fact it does not work
in a network but it works well on the
link say say maybe this if there is only
one thing that is congested this will be
good enough then you forget that when
you come up with TCP another example you
are in your bathtub right and you
realize that you open the key floats but
you do not float you think about they
say why is it then you understand that
and then you used its nan model to
elaborate the design of ship so the
point is that you need a small model but
you have in mind a complex system so so
the way you choose the little model is
with in view the view of the big system
you like the cocktail conversation and
you try to say word around the table
while you try and if you fail you try
and try again so this is a lower right
you'll abrogate that you get these so
net and you get one fine so to
understand the big idea you don't need
the big system you will
understand big system the other state
responses so you get inside by looking
at the caricature and then for the
implementation you have to work more the
question is where do you need theory you
need theory for the inside what do you
need theory for the implementation or
both or neither well the point is that
all the possibilities exist and I will
show you example it is possible that you
need the inside we need the theory for
the inside but not for the
implementation so some example okay this
is packet switching do you need any
theory for this no you don't need any
theory it's a simple idea to trivialize
bhajan DB's 1964 the same time as
nutella as far as I can tell there's an
independent discoveries but you never
know what is less clear is the role of
time it's vacant of action I don't know
if you read the literature some people
will say oh kind of luck did not invite
anything so I went back to his thesis
the thesis proposal in fact 1961 35
pages and it is clear from those 35
pages that he had the full view of the
networking the idea the messages are set
in a store and forward way that you do
writing that you do scheduling is not is
not necessarily first-come first-served
so he had all those ideas already in
inspirator
what he did not have is the idea that
how do i code a packet of information
and all those details but yes yet the
abstract view completely over the other
time
okay so what about this well no series
needed this is I could not find you if
you know pattern but it's probably
Miller so what about this idea of a IND
do you need theory for this well it's an
easy theory right you draw a picture and
you can prove that it will work right
that's that's true and Jen now to go
from TCP the formally IMD to TCP do you
need any theory the answer is no theory
so if you would look at the paper of ng
cop son if he first briefly to the idea
that not to this paper but to the idea
of control if you multiply if you're
proportional control then you have
exponential stability so you knew about
that but it did not need to steal heat
to create TCP because of the time the
theory did not exist there was no way to
understand the control of the network
now if you want to elaborate this later
much later
you can refine TCP because of a better
understanding and yeah I should that DC
PCP in all this but so many people have
worked on this maybe this has been very
fertile attic so you could ask TCP
exists what's the point of going back
and trying to understand it better
trying to improve it well as Mohammed
said well when you are in the data
center the conditions are very default
the objectives are default you need the
default protocol right so you have many
situations where you need different
protocols because the objectives are
tighter and the conditions are change so
you grow more for musician and less for
university
this is an interesting question so we do
not write the typically packets one by
one we're at virtual circuits more and
more right do you wrap flows and if you
have two legs you want to balance the
number of virtual circuits on these two
links and then you could say well there
are two of your scheme one is that when
a new flow arrived I choose the random
you can actually the random path the
other approach is that well we're at the
least busy path does it make a
difference well it depends on the
assumptions that you make about
everything right but the reasonable
assumptions you find out that if you
look at the average head for flow it
doesn't make a difference average type
of flow what I mean by that is that if
five connections use this link with TCP
they will get 1/5 of the rate of the
link each assuming that receiving TCP is
perfect Soto's that it doesn't make a
difference and I could elaborate on one
but you understand that from the
caricature so at that point you say well
maybe I should not try to implement this
option B in the network which is much
more complicated I just random the X
related work it goes back to work with
Tony Tony Ramirez visited us in 1982 or
83
Tony I have a second here so 7 goes
anything so but in any case we wrote a
paper on a simple writing problem but so
a lot of work and many people on writing
is this still yeah yeah dynamic is it
worth doing dynamic routing or not
should you do randomized writing related
story is the work of Frank Kelly when
you say well you at the time it was
looking at phone calls okay when I want
to wrote a rat a phone call from this
point to that point I think the shortest
path but maybe that path will be busy
then I will take an alternate path
so what happens if you do that well if
you analyze the system you discover some
metastability what is happening is that
if it's a bit busy then many connections
will not find the shortest path they
will have to use an alternate path they
will use more resources so the network
will be exposed to a load that is much
larger than it should be and then it
will stick on just it for a long long
time and then congestion will go away
then you remain stable for a long time
when every connection to find short as
well then you will go back because of
fluctuations for a long time will be
congested and so on so you look at that
then you say what I discovered the power
on this simple guy to answer what is the
solution and the solution that Frank
came up passes the idea of start
reservation he said let's use an
alternate path only if they are in a
free pass if not we save them for the
direct connection simple idea but you
avoid this meta study so this is another
example where the inside that you get
for from a very simple caricature is
applicable to a big network so he
applied that to the WT to definitely
all right so another example is this
okay so we've said that to do the
slotted Aloha the series values did
something that you can explain so here I
have to clarify what I mean by theory
because what most of us mean by theory
is not what venket things by theory I
mean that you have a mathematical model
that you use to understand the system
right to get some property versus I
don't Paulo Filho the theory that I need
I don't say I need the consultation
inequalities or anything very
complicated but the the process of
having a mathematical model of the space
yes what is give me a space it is not
okay so easy theory but powerful night
when you want to go from this model that
works well for saying one link one radio
channel to a multi or product network
and and see if that still works there's
a lot of work needed daily initially the
same is going from aimd on one link to
stability of TCP in a network they need
a lot of theory so here's some of some
beautiful working I'm very happy that
Libyan women could join us and of course
work by many many colleagues fact I to
understand the properties of those okay
this is an interesting question that
Kumar worked on he said okay you have a
collection of radios and you want to go
from one video to the other radio what
should you should you transmit as far as
you can to reduce the number of hops
that your packets of to go to or should
you be very polite and take many small
ops and if you think about it it's not
obvious but because the days attention
here you you save the novel fobs
they're NEF less interference with your
create less interference with other
flows so there are some pros and cons
what is the answer
the intuition will not tell you if I'm a
Gentile you need some some little
calculation well so no trigger kept it
so still it gives you the inside because
you well maybe depending on the
situation so if your matter is dense
enough you should if they have enough
flows you should be polite and should oh
sorry I do not mean to so the tech my
paper relate it work by Davichi
kilometers or so those are examples
where the basic questions the basic
scheme that you should use is not
obvious and you have to extract from a
simple model the correct insight to
understand it is that divide all right
another example that that is striking in
transportation system is this brace
paradox and what it says is that it
could happen that if you build a new
road the delays will increase in the
necklace it is very surprising you can
say that if I improve the infrastructure
everything will get better but
paradoxically because the drivers are
self-interested they do not try to
optimize the social welfare they don't
care too much about the other drivers
this leads to this paradox so this is
called so-called - Arkie a messy loose
because the people are making
independent decisions right everybody
loses by making independent decisions
even though they all do a decision that
seems to be better for them that's why
you need regulation that's why you need
laws any politics with you so you need
some theory to really understand what is
happening and this theory has been
elaborated by many people including
Jhansi cyclists rameshwar he and
Valentinian Balaji has looked at
incentives for people to do the right
thing my business it's just another
example that I like in networking so
this is based on the packets met whole
caricature where you have many cards and
you decide that some cats will be first
class and will be expensive and the
other character the same cards will be
cheap so what happens is that the
expensive caps will be less congested
therefore they will be more comfortable
which justifies the higher price even
though that will of the same caps so you
get quality defoliation not by default
technologies but by pricing so which is
quite interesting now network neutrality
gets in the way of ideas like interest
but that's another story isn't a theory
for businesses abisco those ideas of
general value that you understand from a
simple another story in networking is
the idea free hiding so you have people
going and then you you you are in the
middle you say well I will let the other
people hiding and everybody will go a
little bit less
so that's a simple idea but then they're
the elaboration of the coffee consists
of this free-riding in particular
situations require some modeling and
some analysis so the fact that people
will invest less than optimally in
security because they rely on other
people having their virus protection and
should they say I don't need it they do
some some very interesting work by many
people here more generally the idea that
security is a game so again between
people that attack and people that
defend so this game theoretic view leads
to ideas that show that maybe the
villain the most vulnerable part of a
network when it is subject to attacks is
not the same as when it is subject to
random failures so there are strategic
aspects of the network that can be
exploited and that leads to the default
computer so asana thank you for being
here it's not with Johnny Sack EO who is
also here and
this is a famous problem right you have
to accuse it can be served by two
servers and who should what server
should serve what Q what do you do right
so this makes it weighted maximum
maximum weighted matching so very nice
theory but it started with Tony and with
tough Shula's the implementation of that
in two routers it turns out to be too
difficult it's too difficult to compute
the maximum with a machine so you need a
good heuristic and give stick was not
involved theory not much it was inspired
from the idea that you if you do round
robin is better than doing random then
this was done by Nick okay now what
happens
so it's a simple caricature again what
happens if you don't know the rates of
service
I'm not knowing the race beans in the
data center that you done know for
example the the length of the jobs how
long it takes to process the job so what
do you do right one simple idea would be
to say well I will learn the rest as I
go along right I will adapt and then I
will do maximum weighted matching based
on the estimated rate so if you study
the simple model you discover that it
can go unstable so certainty criminals
does not work so you need some theater
looks like that right and it's not
completely obvious and that's word by by
Hampton by young Jean and of course it
it relates to the work on bed it's how
do you choose a channel right Sabrina's
work by my howl and goes back to total
work with pavilion and right
do that both car absolutely this is a
similar story except that we are looking
at the processing Network
so where you are assembling paths and
then your some of those parks and then
they keep on getting the sample together
right then you have servers who can work
on different tasks and the question is
well when should you activate one task
versus the other so you look at the
queue lengths and say what can I do some
kind of maximum weight matching first I
thought yeah that should work but it
does not work you need a new idea and
the idea is what the living came up with
this well you have to look at virtual
deficits so what is happening there is
that they say I have a part here I need
another one to combine them but they say
that I have only one party right so I
will pretend that I have another part
and then I will say I will create a
deficit and you keep track of the
virtual deficit and then you do that
then you do a maximum within my chain
but based on the deficit cues instead of
the actual use so clearly I need to
ensure that you sure that you will
stabilize the system and that works for
a matter you can also use that to
maximize the utility of the flows of
capacity for you so Livan don't ask they
worked on similar problems of impulses
in network there are many other examples
so red metering is like a flow control
for transportation networks and the
first you think about it what does it
make sense to make people wait day
instead of waiting somewhere else what's
the point right might as well it does
make a difference and some theory will
show you yeah yeah I'm meeting a
similarly then you want to elaborate
that into a design then you need to coat
all the complex system that's that's not
obvious you need some theory
so having how to another colleagues that
I don't know I don't know all of them
but so starting a simple model you
convince yourself the value of ischemic
this is another example it has to do
with jobs in the data center as what we
were reminded jobs arrived as a directed
acyclic graph of tasks well sorry arrow
this doesn't mean I produce something it
produces to lead to results that are
processed and then there are the two
results are put together another
processor and we assume that you have
servers maybe this server one can work
on these three tasks server two can work
on the two tasks so this is a model of
one job but imagine that you have a flow
of jobs that arrive so at any given time
I will have a collection of jobs that
are actually performed and some of them
will be in state 1 in state 2 3 4 right
so I will left queues of parts that I
have to process like sub subtasks it
have to go how do i do all this right
and what if I don't know everything
about the processing time zone so the
idea is to look at some backlog energy
in the system okay look at the gradient
algorithm and you come up with
distributed scheme that will stabilize
the network so you have some adaptive
silver allocation in a datacenter the
theory will prove that it works so this
is some work by Hampton and by boy I
will I don't have time to elaborate on
those examples right others condition
build up in an alternate theory to
understand which queues are most likely
to build up is it a combination of
queues that build up or what is
happening so and that led to ideas of
effectiveness quick simulation quick
estimation pricing and so on so some
work by many people sham package
mentioned coasters which of weather
jóska see this stuff wall and that keys
it was fun but again that we started
with two cues or even one cue you look
at one cue so one cue with arrival rate
lambda
so we said new how does it build up but
is the most likely relative to the
Builder well it will build up as if the
service head was lambda and the arrival
rate or mu shockingly right the most
likely rate of growth would be mu minus
lambda instead right Y right and then
say whatever so nice to hear because a
lot of fun then you can look at large
deviations in complex processes where
the large deviation can be a conspiracy
you like college they're all building up
in your system or it can be a
catastrophe like a cancer right and that
process is that that I have those two
features there it can become abnormally
large or they can make jobs that are not
normally high and then understanding
when bad events occur in those systems
is very intriguing and there's some
beautiful work by
oh yeah I had you compare stable
policies the policies that stabilized
Network are you compare them right so
you need some theory there's very nice
work by Nick mumbles on how to compare
home what if you use instead of maximum
meeting matching of qa/qc SMA you do a
simpler policies like the stability of a
log askew first so I saw the longest
queue then if I can serve another queue
in parallel I serve it and then maybe
lunchtime right so will that be stable
that was very puzzling for for herself a
long time Antonis understood the
structure of the the networks for which
this would be stable ensure the examples
of when it is not stable so I think I'll
get started with starting a simple game
casual its maximal matching instead of
maximum waiting machine is the stable
that's much easier you are going to
suffer too
parallel if I can I don't care what
hakuna will that work well no it does
not work and thank God we came up with a
beautiful example that explained so the
power of simple caricature should you do
time of the pricing or should you have
pricing that is based on conjugation in
a very real time way does it make a
difference
well John showed that for large systems
time of the pricing may be good enough
there again you need something it's not
obvious network neutrality what is the
cost of network neutrality what do we
lose by preventing Netflix from playing
your last month provider so Netflix
pairs the direct provider they are not
allowed to pay the aunt provider what do
we lose would customers be worse off
with a bit it's not obvious so some very
nice work Batman John and Galina they've
explained when it is better to let
Comcast let Netflix paid yeah why is
there a problem the sidewalk in shock oh
I can you make cyber insurance effective
market that figure has also some careful
modeling you know mazes very nice right
by golly 910 okay the game theory of
security
beautiful work by John Day he was
looking at a nice question where our
grid shift should be intruder be when it
tries to penetrate your network if he's
too aggressive he will detect it so what
is the the optimum strategy for the
attacker and for the defender where they
should set the threshold for detecting
where you shall set the level of
aggressiveness we the interesting areas
so that's what we have the probability
of any talking about it so the
challenges so that's a review my view of
Novation start with simple understanding
of the pole then try to extend to the
design
the big question in networking is
networks are complex and you want to
control them so you monitor the network
and then you control and you make
decisions what information should you
collect so I give you an example where
knowing how many connections there were
on different links was not helpful you
do not need that so there's a lot of
information that you could collect most
of it is not useful to find that that
you need some careful thought experiment
suit we analyzed the basic effects right
what do you thought on I should you
learn because you don't know that
many aspects of the system so many
questions this is an example of the
DARPA program where they want to have
radios that share the spectrum in a fair
and efficient way but they are not
co-designed so you want to limit the
role of standards because they slow down
innovation so what should those radios
do right what should they sense what
what should you control what do you
adjust those that we are waving working
with and not on the problem for almost
two years now
it's really challenging even at the
conceptual level is another challenge is
processing networks but we talked a lot
about communication network in the panel
they said well computation so the
processing is the focus of networks data
centers are certainly an example
manufacturing networks how do you
improve the flow of test lot freeze
coming out of the plant and that's not
simple all hospitals are processing
Network I've worked a little bit with
obstacles and they are way behind in
terms of logistics task allocation
resource allocation so there's a lot to
be done
the service in the industry more
generally so those are to me important
networks for that bank for some good
understanding
alright conclusions okay theory provides
insight for new schemes I should you
queue right
what should you add new schedule should
you schedule in each node should do you
do
flow control so should the quality of
service be done by having different
classes of service in the routers or
should you do it end-to-end what of this
should you look at your kill the
neighbors kills all the kids were what
you what is the information that you
need to control this the system should
you optimize should use your simple
schemes like xx operation should your
time of the pricing to comprising
dynamic pricing what our collaboration
signals among different entities but is
the minimum information that you need to
exchange right what about incentive
compatibility how do I know that the
information I get is truthful it's not
so many problems but few years to
provide design tools to not only getting
inside but also tools right so there are
many examples of this time so conclusion
networking is not done we have had a
much improved understanding in the last
few years for some types of problems but
there are many complex challenges that
remain to be solved the key theoretical
insights should not be obscure by the
details of the technology many
networking process are alphabet soup
right understanding networking is not
understanding details of protocols it's
understanding the higher level
principles ok so keep up the good work
we need your insight and we need your
innovations most of the good work is by
the people who I will if you will
indulge me for two minutes I will make
some final remarks we very much say it
has been quite a trip for me I thought
they will stay 9 months when I came to
Berkeley
- there's been 43 years I want to thank
all the funding agencies for the support
would you save my industry friends
odisha I'm an here I managed a terribly
is ROI is the right Danny shall cares
not here all go so I manage the image so
the amazing colleagues and students for
the sun-times
working with us being a lot of fun and
also for putting my name on your
perversion it's quite the gig when you
think about it right okay what's he
saying my family and friends for the
yeah I think quite a lot of to us I was
a sec specifically for this workshop the
organizers did a wonderful job thank you
for selecting the speakers except for
the last one I was a cycle so the
Science Institute I want to thank in a
row for contributing to this workshop or
to thank Annie for tolerating my wasting
addiction to research I used to say that
I was living a life of self-imposed
misery but and he does not like that
Pavin from for preventing me from
becoming a depressed drunk washing
machine repairman which was a much more
likely outcome for me than doing to
academia Medina I'm very grateful so
thank you all very much thank you
okay so I hope that the dinner will be
good but that is at this point this plan
to take a picture yeah so we don't
really know where to go so we're just
going to go right out there
[Music]